aujourd'hui c'est noël à quelque chose
près nous attend c'est pourquoi pas
parce que je vous offre en partenariat
avec asus cette jolie petite chose c'est
une asus lire avant cela l'iran bolt qui
joue d'offres c'est celle que j'utilise
actuellement que juste la flamme will
bourbon doit alors je viens juste de
l'installer d'ouvrir je la teste pour
vous comme ça elles ont en pris l'air du
studio les bonnes notes motion les
bonnes vagues donc ça c'est plutôt cool
je vous parle aujourd'hui justement de
ce produit ce produit qui est
intéressant et qui a plusieurs fonctions
trois fonctions principales
et ça c'est cool
[Musique]
regardez-moi ça comme c'est mignon c'est
une petite enceinte c'est une enceinte
n'est pas réellement une enceinte
c'est une enceinte qui sert à plein de
choses différentes et qui vraiment
toutes couleurs je fais vraiment
attention parce que c'est dans ce n'est
pas à moi elle est à vous qui allez
gagner une enceinte qui est très sympa
j'ai pas enlever les plastiques soient
côté je vous ai laissé les petits
plastique donc elle se branche derrière
la sur l'électricité vous pouvez
l'utiliser en routeur ou bien branché
votre connexion internet ici tout vous
expliquer dans quelques instants
et en plus de ça je trouve que a vu ça
fait un beau packaging georges pour lui
l'expérience fonctionne boxing vraiment
cool vous venez d'ouvrir les enveloppes
comme ce que de petites chaussettes
comme ça hop là oh la la
vous enlevez ensuite vous avez une
espèce de boîte qui vient d'ouvrir comme
ça à l'intérieur et poser vos climat
voice et vous lever vous avez tout le
câblage nécessaire même si vous êtes en
angleterre pour une rue branchée si vous
voulez sinon vous avez votre câble
ethernet pour utiliser comme un routeur
principal ça c'est pratique
je l'expliquais dans quelques instants
vous avez tout votre câblage une petit
dock à l'intérieur carte de garantie
donc ça c'est plutôt bien enfin que la
dira boys et un routeur wifi mesh avec
amazon alexa quand je vous dis routeur
wifi mesh sais pas si ça vous parle en
fait routeur wifi je pense que là vous
aurez compris vous mettez de l'internet
ça fait routeur s'en va par du wifi
assez classique wifi mesh c'est un pote
en gros ce qu'il faut comprendre que ce
routeur enceinte connectée va vous
servir à deux choses principales déjà
d'un côté routeur vous allez broncher
sans votre arrivée internet est là ça va
pouvoir diffuser en wifi vous servir de
routeurs principal pour diffuser un
signal wifi et lorsque vous en avez
plusieurs des pouvoirs forme de
répéteurs vous avez un principal plus le
deuxième et 6 et ça parce que si vous
avez une grande maison en leurs murs
très épais ou le signal passe mal eh
bien vous en mettez plusieurs ça va
prendre votre wifi ça va le répéter ce
qui fait que vous aurez du wifi partout
dans votre maison différents étages au
grand extrémités pouvez configurer comme
un routeur principale ou alors
l'utiliser et ses enfants d'haïti
vraiment le plus intéressant avec
d'autres routeurs imaginez vous avez une
box en routeur principal et vous
l'utilisez lui comme un routeur seconde
heure pour venir amplifier un signal
pour venir répéter un signal eh bien il
est complètement compatible avec tous
les routeurs du marché moi par exemple
j'ai un routeur principal rouge et une
box avec bouygues telecom et bien lui
je les connecter routeur secondaire il
est connecté sur mon bouton principal
qu'est maddox bouygues telecom et paf
il répète le signal et jacques huppert
signale ici et ça pour moi
gros point positif et c'est je pense en
tout cas la fonctionnalité la plus cool
de ce produit non pas que le fait
d'avoir une enceinte connecter quinze
alexa ne soit pas cool mais sans tout
cas ça le mérite d'être original on a un
réseau maillé tribande qui compatible
avec la technologie eye mèche d'asus bon
ça je vous le passez un côté un peu
technique ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que c'est bien pour répéter le signal
c'est bien pour avoir plein de routeurs
chez vous et pour avoir l'internet pour
homogène
ça c'est le le truc principal à retenir
en plus de ça est truqué vraiment cool
c'est que c'est une enceinte connectez
vous avez ici deux haut parleurs de 8
watts et là vous avez un espèce de
système de caisson de résonance de
chaque côté pour venir apporter un peu
plus de groove
j'ai bien un peu de basses et c'est vrai
que je trouve que s'envoient cette
source est pas mal vous avez ici vos
boutons de volume le petit bouton pour
venir un ou tel appareil
le petit bouton de lecture je peux
utiliser bien évidemment encore 5
bluetooth entre par exemple une
communication entre mon téléphone est
lui directement sur mon compte spotify
objat puis là je mets la lecture ça
m'emballe du son c'est pratique c'est
sympa donc de ce point de vue là c'est
bien après son but l'histoire une
enceinte connectés c'est vrai qu'il
développe un son qui est correct qui est
clair qui est de bonne qualité
il ya un regain de basse vu le petit
format delà de la bête ça c'est plutôt
bien d'autant plus que vous avez un son
qui compatible seulement dts et qui dans
l'absolu je trouve marche plutôt pas mal
et en plus de ça vous avez des petits
micros là et qui vont servir parce que
vous allez vouloir par les amazones
alexa l'idée est toute bête et elle est
vachement bien c'est qu'en fait vous
avez les deux micros qui vont écouter et
par rapport aux sont cuits en train de
diffuser va créer une espèce de leur
phase pour reconnaître uniquement votre
voix dont pouvait être un petit peu loin
par les voies normales avec du son qui
est assez fort et dire à alexa si avec
ça ça ça marchera sarko être à votre
voix et ça c'est une technique est
plutôt intéressante mais qui va vous
aviez surtout de deux propositions la
voie du relais ou de venir appuyer
directement dessus manuellement nous
recoupé la musique comme ça point
positif
et comme je viens de vous le dire vous
avez amazon alexa qui intègre et ça
c'est plutôt bien
ça vous permet effectivement de
commander tous les objets de votre
maison utilisée tous les services qui
sont compatibles avec alexa notamment un
compte spotify prime fayet ya pas mal de
possibilités
le congrès sur amazon musique et tutti
quanti donc le tout cas plutôt bien en
plus de ça vous avez toute une partie
qui est sécurisé notamment pour le
contrôle parental
donc ça c'est quand même relativement
assurant surtout quand on voit qu'on est
au coeur en fête de votre sécurité à la
maison tout ce qui remplace par la
transit par là donc là vous êtes quand
même relativement tranquille vous avez
un contrôle parental la gestion des
activités internet vous pouvez mettre
désordre pour restreindre être connecté
à telle heure à telle heure mais pas à
telle autre heure donc ça c'est ça peut
être relativement tranquillisants dans
ce conte et parents vous avez un filtre
de contenu ceci plutôt pas mal pour des
enfants
vous avez tout un système de prévention
contre les intrusions un blocage des
sites malveillants et une détection et
blocages des objets connectés qui
pourraient être potentiellement
infectées pc un logiciel qui est
développé par trend micro et qui
garantit avait donc ça plutôt bien et
tout ça se pilote grâce à une
application asus l'ira qui est très
simple qui est très sympa tout ce genre
d'essais libres et votre petit réseau
qui s'affiche
et après vous avez accès ici à toutes
vos informations carte du réseau et ses
invités sont barton compagnie donc ça
c'est plutôt cool pour moi ce produit il
intéressant pour deux types de personnes
lorsque vous avez un problème de wifi à
la maison et vous avez besoin d'un
répéteur ça c'est plutôt intéressant
avec le wifi mais ça marche parfaitement
bien c'est bien site sécurisé ou alors
lorsque vous voulez en routeur basse
pourquoi pas celui là il est
relativement intéressant le côté
enceinte et bien le fait d'avoir amazon
avec ça c'est aussi intéressant enfin
voilà il faut que c'est un produit qui
s'écoule et qui comptent aux alentours
des 250 euros ça dépend bien évidemment
des revendeurs si ça produit qui vous
intéresse si vous avez un lien en bas
dans la description il y en a un où
l'une d'entre vous qui aura la chance de
repartir avec cette boîte la veille
c'est toi qui chantera de jean petit
matin un petit câlin vous allez recevoir
chez vous pour participer c'est hyper
simple vous avez un lien en bas dans la
description vous cliquez ya un petit jeu
vous participez et vous pourrez
peut-être remporter le lira voice d'asus
ça c'est plutôt cool
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous trouvez cette solution est
intéressante est que vous en aurez vous
éventuellement besoin dans votre
intérieur oui non quoi comment vous
marquez tout ça en bas en commentaire
quant à nous on se donne rendez vous dès
demain et bonne chance à tous ceux qui
ont participé et félicitations aux
gagnants ou à la gagnante que je ne
connais pas encore qu'on saura dans
quelques jours je voulais marquer bien
évidemment sur les réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs mais bon joint dès maintenant
twitter
monsieur gros tout attaché et instagram
monsieur underscore gros est aussi sur
facebook voilà tout va bien vous
embrasse
à demain châu